à guémar aussi devant l'hémicycle
bonsoir guillemin c'est le dernier râle
bon cas d'un feuilleton parlementaire
qui dure maintenant depuis plus de trois
semaines
et oui bonsoir c'est fanny oui comme
vous l'avez dit donc un dernier acte qui
doit mettre fin à cet état d'urgence
sanitaire donc entrer en vigueur vous
l'avez dit le 24 mars dernier alors ce
texte comme vous l'imaginez bien il
divise parmi les députés mais il
rencontre également une très forte
opposition
parmi les sénateurs vous l'avez dit le
sénat a rejeté ce matin
ce texte alors qu'est ce que reproche la
chambre haute à ce texte
eh bien ils reprochent de prétendre
mettre fin à cet état d'urgence
sanitaire tout en conservant la
possibilité de restreindre certaines
libertés comme par exemple la liberté de
circuler la liberté d'accueillir du
public dans certains établissements ou
encore la liberté de se rassembler et
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a annoncé le
sénateur philippe bas à l'issue de cette
séance du sénat le seul filet bas le
président de la commission des lois du
sénat il a déclaré que le gouvernement
voulait je cite conserver les moyens de
l'état d'urgence sans le dire est que le
citoyen avait davantage besoin de vérité
et de responsabilité que de risquer une
forme d'infantilisation et parmi les
députés ici opposé à ce texte et ils
sont très nombreux le constat est
similaire écoutez je pense
qu'aujourd'hui nous maintient dans un
urgences sanitaires à l'état d'urgence
sanitaire pardon
expliquez-moi les français on leur a
demandé d'aller voter
mais français ont quasiment leur
quotidien hormis les gestes barrière qui
fonctionne et on leur dit qu'on est
toujours en état d'urgence sanitaire
il ya d'autres outils qui sont
disponibles pour l'exécutif que de
m'accueillir en état d'urgence et à
l'urgence
on a enfin des habitués mais il ya cinq
ans
peu de français savez ce que ça veut
dire état d'urgence à remonter aux
années 60 la précédente
donc attention aux privations de liberté
alors c'est donc à la chambre basse qui
revient le dernier mot comme le
prévoient nos institutions alors malgré
l'opposition de nombreux députés il ne
devrait pas y avoir beaucoup de suspense
ici ou palais bourbon car c'est le
gouvernement a perdu stricto sensu sa
majorité parlementaire elle devrait
pouvoir compter sur les voix de nombreux
députés centristes et donc voir adopter
cette sortie de l'état d'urgence une
sortie en trompe l'oeil comme l'a
qualifiée le sénat merci gaymard aussi